and we we've got some crazy uh breaking
news
i mean it's it's been ridiculous with
the chronovirus yeah non-stop breaking
news that's crazy california declares a
state of emergency over coronavirus
after
first death
so now we have what how many states is
that we've got florida washington and
california now how is it what's the
definition of pandemic how is it not a
pandemic yet because the world health
organization needs to say it is
what are they waiting for
it's spreading across germany germany
germany said it was yeah well so the
pandemic so here's the thing right i
have this story but i'm sick and tired
of everyone being like it's not as big
as the flu okay well uh wait that's not
the right one let me uh where's that
here we go the flu and the new
coronavirus have similar symptoms but
the coronavirus is far deadlier here's
how the two compare
the first thing that needs to be brought
up is the chronovirus mortality rate was
actually increased nearly doubling
nearly doubling it was two it was around
two percent
that's what they had said and then the
world health organization said actually
it's 3.4 around the world yeah so then
it went up a little more right oh so
i've seen it go up a little more but i'm
not gonna i don't i don't have that
source so i'm gonna
yeah so i saw some people saying 3.6
yeah but 3.4 was the official like quote
so it is substantially worse than
people have been saying it is
but we are actually talking about
something and i have to bring it up see
we were talking about how
karen
will bring about essential oils to cure
the coronavirus and we're and and this
is literally before we press live and
i'm like no we should actually ask the
question
because i've heard that karen is a
gendered racial slur
i mean it makes sense
because it's like amy klobuchar i mean
when you say that i know exactly the
type of person you're and you know what
you're thinking of the exact haircut
yeah this is i don't think it can be a
racial slur because it is against white
people there's there's like there's like
four or five different haircuts i
believe now there's like one character
they're all carrying this on the theme
yeah so now that we've deviated from the
more serious topics we did that for a
reason levity so now that you're all
freaking out and sweating bullets like
the girona virus is going to kill me we
do like a little funny thing karen it's
just joe calm down everybody the world's
not ending except i tell you right
except all the karen's they're pissed oh
yeah dude we're gonna get angry comments
they don't watch us oh okay yeah all
right we have nothing to worry about
they're gonna ask me to start selling
essential oils
no oh geez so
here i want to show you i want to show
you this uh
one death huh and then they declared it
but here's the thing man
here's the thing man look at this video
what you want what's this this is in
queens this is in queens so this is this
is this was great i talked about it
earlier for those that are just
listening
a dude collapsed on the ground
i don't think chronovirus is not
confirmed and you know it could be
anything but i'll tell you what there's
two things i'll say the first you could
be taking a nap
right what if he's totally normal just i
see people sleeping on the streets in
new york all the time just fall over
just not wearing this flat ass nothing
under the middle of a panda and his arms
are like just straight out all right
it's a little weird yeah i'll be honest
so so here's the thing yeah
anywhere near that nope these people are
like oh let me get a picture it's like
over here i would be heading the other
way as fast as i could what are they
doing let me let me give there's a baby
stroller oh my gosh turn that thing
around and get out of there what are
they doing i'll give everybody some some
some say
look look baby look he has chronovirus i
was i was in chicago and smoke started
billowing out of a building downtown and
what did everyone do run to the building
they ran towards it why would you do
that i mean this was this was a while
ago smart like smart cameras weren't as
popular like when this was gone as well
so they were they weren't going to get
photos for instagram they were going to
just check it out and i you know what i
did i was on my bike and i'm like whoop
other direction yeah i'm like dude i was
14 when a couple buildings got knocked
down i'm like i'm not going to overreact
but first of all if there's emergency
services i need to come and help this
guy exactly get out of the way dude
don't walk up and start forming a circle
around the guy like hey look there's a
guy in the ground yeah makes no sense
nice people are nuts that's what you
know when he gets a car accident on the
side of the road and suddenly there's
traffic for days because there's just
the onlookers on the other side of the
road what are you looking at there's
someone heard over there keep moving i
got a crazy story maybe maybe maybe i'll
save it for the end of the segment oh
save it if it's that crazy although i
really want [ __ ]
it's brutal man anyway let me let me say
this about this guy yeah
here's my question to you guys
if
this happens like from any illness like
let's say somebody gets the flu and
they're walking down the street and they
pass out do we just not talk about it
because the flu is normal
or is this not normal you know what i
mean this doesn't seem normal to me
right i mean if you have the flu and
you're
if it it doesn't hit you like that like
it seems the coronal virus really hits
you really fast
but you know
if it's hitting you like this we got to
talk about it it's a pandemic it's
seriously affecting people all over and
it's hitting him like this the dude i
don't remember who it was some some
leader got it on like he started he was
in mid-speech or something oh the
iranian guy the iranian guy that was
crazy he's in the middle of a speech
talking about it no no no the other guy
was speaking he was like standing next
to him oh okay is that what and then all
of a sudden he starts like wiping sweat
off he's like why am i sweating so much
and people and then and he had the
coronavirus yeah
we got to talk about it he did it
definitely i love it dude a bunch of
iranian government officials have died
one in ten yeah the flu
not died
the flu does not do this to people
right no and and the hospitalization
rate for the flu is way less
so you've got 20 percent of people in
the hospital look i'm going to say this
there was a period where
in the past couple of days i was kind of
i was kind of like coming down like you
know what i don't think it really is as
bad i think i think we're getting i
think these are okay and i'm saying this
and i'm like oh man
nah this is bad we're up to like what
nine deaths or 10 deaths 11 11 yes yeah
in the us there's that one in california
that pushed them over the edge but what
didn't some guy say that the death
rate's probably way higher than we even
know because they're not testing and not
reporting it remember i was talking okay
i don't know
sorry podcast there was a person who
died in uh washington before all this
mess went down and they did like a
post-mortem exam and they're like holy
moly this dude died of coronavirus
nobody knew nobody knew he died and
they're like oh we should check out like
cause of death maybe he'd been in the
hospital for less than 24 hours or
something because that's what they do so
yeah they checked him out and they're
like oh wow not cool wow so so well what
you just said is that because there's
not that many like
well the motor mortality rate might be
higher right yeah but that's because
we're not testing as many people right
wouldn't they're they're going to start
then
if that was the case like if we tested
everybody and found out there are so
many more people that have it then right
there will skyrocket well wouldn't it be
the mortality rate is who dies from it
right right so wouldn't the mortality
rate go down no no no no if the dead
people aren't being tested for it
correct we're like this person died of a
strange respiratory illness oh okay okay
we don't know the people who are dying
we don't know if it's all coronavirus
related stuff i see it's kind of crazy
when you hear like that fam a family in
new york got it
and i'm wondering if like i got so so
here's what happened i'm getting a point
where i'm like man i really don't care
anymore
it's like how many you do
you do you do care up it's really hard
it's hard to keep caring when it's like
well when everyone's trying to downplay
it too and like it's not that big of a
deal we've got this under control no you
don't
no you don't i there's there's many
cases of people that are like i thought
i might have had it so i called the
hospital to try to get i called the
coronavirus hotline they sent them oh
you saw something else which sent them
to another thing which sent them to
another thing which sent them back to
the coronavirus hotline and then finally
they got someone who was like we don't
have tests right now you know my
favorite you know my favorite things
my favorite is the conspiracy conspiracy
theory
that the trump administration is
purposefully jamming up the system so
that no one knows what's going on i'm
like why would they do that it's like so
ridiculous yeah why would they do that
does he want panic to happen when people
don't trust the government and everyone
goes nuts right no they want to show
nobody under control yeah exactly
i can't stand the conspiracy mumbo
garbage
so mumbo garbage i just want everyone to
be prepared because this is clearly much
worse than they're letting on well check
this out so
let me show you this article right and
you can show this to all of your friends
when they're like dude i don't care it's
like not even as bad as the flow the
most crucial difference between the flu
and the chronovirus is that the latter
has been far deadlier whereas about
point one percent of people who get the
flu die the coronavirus's death rate is
now at three point four percent based on
the current numbers of cases and deaths
and i'll tell you what fox one point one
that's the flu it's like oh okay so it's
34 times worse and you want
there was a they did a graphic on fox
news they were talking about this and
they said that there was a pandemic in
1957 and this isn't even a pandemic and
then they said that the mortality rate
for the last 157 was uh 0.6 globally 0.6
0.6 and this is 3.43 globally 0.4
globally wow dude that's a lot of people
how is it not a pandemic it is a
pandemic as far as i'm concerned all
right well i don't see you in a lab coat
mr fancy that's true jesus let me follow
that up with i am just using my soy
jesus powers to make that
declaration if if it can be a pandemic
in 57 it can be a pandemic now that is
right okay i have spoken
the technical definition of a pandemic
is prevalent over a whole country or the
world oh and i could argue that this is
prevalent over a large position of the
world is it not
all over the world right now germany
said it was a pandemic yeah it's over
it's over the entire globe you know what
man south america hasn't really been hit
they have a case or two i think i'm
feeling really bored with when i get
down there like a dude collapsed in the
street today and i saw that first story
and i was like whoa
and then i sat and for a second and i
was like
but is it really a story like dude how
many times can we talk about this i know
right but but no but like let's be real
i don't think we're planning on going up
to new york anytime soon i was gonna go
this weekend and now it's like now so my
birthday is on saturday i was gonna go
up and hang with some friends we're
gonna play some magic
play some magic now i think i might just
uh there's some magic here dude not go
out
not go into new york city great who has
coronavirus yeah they do yeah so it's
there i i mean i touching a gas handle
on the way or at least for nine days
right so here's what i was reading
though there was uh
i was reading so i was reading a lot
about the flu and the chronovirus
and one of the things that i read was
that a lot of people already have
immunity to different flu strains okay
especially people have gotten sick maybe
got a mild form of it when they were
younger but
that could actually have an effect on
some various strains of the flu so it's
like basically they were saying
if you if you get the flu you'll get an
immunity to that and some similar
strains like your body erect but right
the chronovirus is novel like literally
completely no immunity to it at all
right this is all this strain is
completely novel and they think it's
zoonotic that's why i think it's totally
novel
did you hear about the chick whose dog
got coronavirus she got the dog got it
the dog got it
so those dog masks are viable oh they
are yeah say so yeah so uh you know for
those that don't understand facebook and
amazon have been banning commercials
like in advertising advertisements that
promote things like dog face masks
yeah and then banning it for for the
record though i am really sad for that
dog who has coronavirus dog got it does
that mean because that sucks so so i
don't know sorry dog here here's the way
i feel right now i'm kind of like i'm
just ready for it to be over
because i don't know like a guy
collapsing i'm pretty sure that's what
everyone wants yeah i'm kind of feeling
we all want this to be but i'm not
agitated i'm not agitated i'm boring i
don't even think it's close to being
over yeah dude did you hear they're
gonna they might postpone the olympics
in japan yeah the uk is gonna do like a
three month like
take a break from everything
work school how that's supposed to work
do you hear about that like what are
they gonna do life on hold they called
it right life on hold for three months
wow
i think the funny i think i think the
[ __ ] well i think i mean no nope
everyone just freezes like let's just
put everyone on deep freeze
where's the food gonna come from that's
why you should go and pick up oh
are you prepared are you no but uh i
think it's funny that there's so many
people who are just like and we talked
about it last time but i'll never get
over it when they're like
and now the uk is like for three months
you're going to stay indoors and hide
yeah i'm excited i'm exaggerating
obviously yeah they just said like avoid
pubs avoid well that means they can't go
in
sports avoid yeah they can't do anything
that's it for british people i kind of
feel like you know what man crazy you
just gotta just gotta grin and bear it
you know what i think you just gotta go
get the corona i'm kidding don't do that
no just go get it and get it over it's
the fear you know what i mean it's like
i'm tired of being afraid just go get it
and then get over get over with
okay so i don't know maybe we should
have actually talked about what
california is doing and why they're
doing it or like those guys licking the
mosques or something yeah
these crazy people in every different
country in
china elevator panels yeah the whole
they're not licking the elevator panels
they're not they're giving it to other
people that's oh so wait they're licking
the shrines and then other shrine is
getting infected
the shrine has grown about the shrine
dies
another sign just becomes so like you
ever see that story there's a funny
story where uh well it's kind of sad
actually there was a statue of i think
the virgin mary yeah and there was water
pouring from her eyes or something okay
so people started licking it up
and it was a backed up sewage pipe from
like the building next door that was
leaking water on it
they were licking it up oh dude your
tears tasted this is why
this is holy this is why we get
coronavirus
because of things like this
oh my goodness that is gross yeah so
like the shrine would be considered a
fomite that was a funny story oh yeah
that's a thing that's going to be likely
to carry infection uh and if everybody's
licking it
it's very likely to carry infections
word of the day is so might
the lady who died in california how old
was she did they say the lady she was
relatively wasn't she in her 50s yeah
that's what i want to know about all
these people that are dying are they
healthy well the dude in queens was 25.
they take care of themselves and they
don't know what happened i know some 25
year olds that are not healthy at all
yeah so i knew that my question remains
i knew a dude isn't i'm i'm he's vegan
and he only ate like mac and cheese
and like spaghetti noodles that's not
healthy and he didn't know i was really
sick all the time that's right i'm like
dude listen man like you take vitamins
like ramen and sweet macaroni and cheese
that's that's not really i mean
macaroni noodles it wasn't mac and
cheese like obviously that makes no
sense he's never heard the term eat your
vegetables no well probably not no
their people have no idea what they're
doing they're just dumb like even if all
you do is eat pizza all day just dude
please anyone everyone do research i was
wrong about that lady by the way she was
in her 90s
in california yeah the first lady who
died there did you guys but it's for
sure it was it was coronavirus
yeah
do you know what bloomberg said like
that clip that went viral where he was
like if you get old and get sick well
you lived a good life be on your way
it's like isn't he like 80. 78. oh my
god how do you where all right that's a
tough question though do we do we just
tell this like old woman like well
you're 90 and you got the coronavirus so
uh here's a pillow and um a gatorade
we'll be seeing you like what do you got
a message saying the dog didn't get the
virus he just carried it on his fur
always oh the dog itself didn't didn't i
read that he had yeah no i read i read a
story specifically saying it was human
to animals i need to see it to believe
it yeah we're gonna have to we'll have
to see i'm getting a different source
i'm just looking at the other side of
the coin that's that's my job i'm
curious
i'm all about that it was on the daily
mail and it was like a picture of a lady
and she was holding like a
little white i can't say the name of the
dog
oh no yeah because it's a bad word
because it's a bad word on youtube oh
really yeah it's the zoo dog yeah the
poop poop zoo
i can't say it i can't say oh seriously
you can't do that
they
do you know who sargon is yeah they
fully demonetized his channel for
harassment for like mocking like he was
like what did i do i don't even
understand yeah so i'm like dude i'm
telling you man people say things like
oh huku's just swear i'm like dude no
you do not understand
they are looking for any excuse to give
you the banhammer
it is the hammers the soy the soy hammer
as i know it soy hammers did you find
the dog thing i did i guess it was a
weak positive so he was carrying it but
he's not likely to die of it but he'll
infect other dogs so he could be an
infection he's dog patient zero oh it's
gonna be cool to make like a zombie
movie but it's like dogs
only the dogs are zombies that'd be
awesome and like the only zombies don't
attack the dogs the dogs are just left
alone
and then they gain sentience and they're
like man
i'm going with it actually
a really a really fun idea for like a
short would be if a zombie apocalypse
happened but it's from the perspective
of cats
so like the cats just don't care that
humans are going after each other and
they mind their own business they're
like finally
some space free out there killing all
the birds
okay so this was like the least serious
cronovirus thing we've ever done okay
all right so let's just let's just yeah
one 90 year old died in california but
the fact remains though they locked it
down they locked california down yeah
they're locking the uk down like they
walk down italy it's starting to happen
and it's only a matter of time before
the states start locking down everything
oh totally
here's what you need okay so if you've
if you somehow managed to make it this
far in our in our rambling jokes about
like dangerous pandemic yeah
what you need to realize is that
as they start doing these states of
emergency it means they are preparing to
start locking things down setting up
checkpoints doing what they need to do
i'm not saying they will do it i'm
saying they need to be able to do it and
so they they've enacted this which means
the first step in getting the point
where they're like business is closed
school is closed
and also people got to realize that dude
there are barely any hospital beds in
hospitals
you know it's like 2.6 beds per per what
10 000 people or a thousand people or
something ridiculous number yeah yeah
that's crazy and so if this hits people
and hits a lot of people
then what do you do they're going to be
like we're not china we don't have the
ability to build a hospital in 10 days
what what do you want we only have a
little less than 800 000 staffed beds
and community hospitals in the entire
country yep oh my goodness what's up 800
000. hold on
we only have 6 000 hospitals in the us
wow i'm impressed so you
you were right about china but you said
we're not like you know we said we're
not like china we can't just build a
hospital in 10 days right right we're
not like china we can't just lock people
in their homes with steel barricades and
start loading them into camps also true
yes that's what chyna is doing so when i
hear that like china's got things under
control i'm like
of course they locked everybody in a
camp yeah there's videos of them going
up to a woman's apartment and taking a
giant steel bar and putting it between
her door and the wall so they can't open
it so she can't get out no food like
whatever the food you get she can't get
out her her and her family were trapped
and she didn't even have the virus
that she came back from wuhan and they
were like nope
there's other videos of them like
dragging people from their homes yeah
they they knocked ladies over in the
street because they wouldn't wear masks
a couple you know what sometimes
i'm willing to accept the risk of the
chronovirus if it means we have freedom
i'll always earn the side of freedom
yeah through that you know look if you
want security and you want to make sure
that the virus doesn't spread then you
can ask big brother to come and stand in
front of your door
yeah exactly
that's actually a really funny thing
about jail
what's the meme it's like jail is
everything that socialists want the
government pays for your health care
they pay for your housing they give you
a job they pay for education that's
pretty hilarious
it's the most extreme version of
government doing everything for you now
we don't want that nope so i don't know
what do you guys think you think the the
world's going to end
no
definitely not do you think the the
world's not going to end but but but
here's the thing man oh oh there was a
viral video i saw look i can't believe
we're talking about this for so much but
there was there was a viral video of a
lady that was sent to me she uh posted
this to facebook she works at a port i
don't know which port she works at okay
but she was like she walks around
filming and she's like this is weird
there there ain't no canisters and she's
like pointing to the big shipping crates
the big like the big metal boxes
right freighters or whatever and she's
like it's empty and she shows there's no
people there's no shipments or anything
and it's probably because china turned
the boats around yeah like when they
started we were shipping masks
american masks made in china and chinese
government took them back right so
that's probably
you know what i think too probably a lot
of things that they're turning back and
keeping people don't realize that right
now so much of our stuff is made in
china there's probably gonna be a huge
ripple effect yeah it's kind of like a
traffic jam
like
everyone slows down and then it goes in
a wave backwards in the traffic jam so
all of the factories that got shut down
in china like i'm i'm willing to but
there's going to be a skateboard
shortage not even kidding everything
yeah everything yep skateboards what
isn't made in china right you know so
you're going so right so
right now we have supplies because
things got shipped in right mm-hmm but
next month you're gonna be like that's
weird like there's nothing on the shelf
what's up with that hmm yeah hopefully
we'll be like we're done with
coronavirus where is everything we gotta
figure out what to do apparently trump's
getting flack because he said something
like well the good news is at least
people are staying here and they're
buying from us
and then i'm excu excuse me everyone
else was of course like oh haromf oh the
president oh how dare he say that in
psychology i mean he's right it's a
passive comment he's right we should we
should make the stuff we should be
making our own stuff so you know how
we're telling everyone else to prepare
like to buy their own food yeah maybe
the us should be like producing their
own other stuff you have to work but
hold on you the worst part is california
makes most of the food oh gosh
seriously yeah well yup we should all be
growing our own food man california is
is lost
that place is so messed up yeah i feel
bad for the northeastern parts where
it's like they're they're more moderate
and they have like small towns but
you're like north of san francisco you
mean like yeah
yeah yeah but but everything about that
state is just like a mess and it's gonna
be really scary because we did mention
this last time if the if the homeless
population gets it because they have a
massive
massive homeless problem what do you
mean everywhere
it's when it's probably already
happening i'm sure it's already out
there yep because they're out in the
streets and you know what they're not in
the home and you know they're doing in
uh i i think it's reading maybe not
running i don't know there's some place
where they're interning the homeless
people like they've basically just said
we are taking you to a camp
we are controlling your finances and you
can't do anything until you can prove
you're like fiscally sound or whatever
how do you do that if you're stuck in an
internment camp not not only that how do
you violate someone's constitutional
rights by just locking up because
they're homeless and you think they're
unwell i mean it's tough because you we
can do like what is it called like a
5150 or something what's that where they
like they take like the cops will come
and lock they'll just take you to a an
asylum
just boom take it yeah it's called like
i think it's called the 5150s is that
what goes on in florida i don't know
like they show up to your house and
they're like it's a wellness check and
we're locking up for three days and
they'll take you and bring you to the
hospital and i'll give you pills and
other crazy stuff
yeah okay so they
take care of you
i mean yeah
sick
what if i got mad at my neighbor and i
was like oh he was doing something crazy
and they show up and they're like you're
taking us this is one of the things they
talk about with red flag laws right
they're concerned so yeah 5150 is a
california law code for a temporary
involuntary psych commitment of
individuals who present a danger to
themselves or others oh my gosh oh man
yeah you know what i'm gonna hold on
if there is ever like a mass internment
camps of like people being rounded up
it's starting in california oh yeah 100
it's already kind of happening there
should we uh should we jump over the
super chats and then yeah all right i'm
done with this yeah i don't even
whatever man all right we got a bunch of
super chats hey thanks for everybody for
hanging out we're going to do our best
but
i want to i want to just let everybody
know the more we get uh the more viewers
coming we've got almost 7 000 the harder
it is to actually go through all the
super chat so we'll do our best
archurable 26 says yes this podcast
seems to be made made of beanie yep it
is oh oh adam's wearing his beanie i'm
wearing my beanie today it's true there
it is jimmy lauren says hey tim got my
rice can't wait for taco night i had
tacos again tonight we had this is so
awesome we did slow cooked chicken with
like a uh what was it it was a buffalo
wild wings asian asian soup asian zing
and then i put cheese and sour cream on
it taco night we found and i didn't put
rice on it but we did do black beans the
other day that's right gotta do it gotta
do it we're getting used to it
archer bowl says beanie cast irl with
added beanie flavor yep there's the
flavor we're trying to get neem to do a
spice for us yeah no
i'm just kidding just a note what up
name
just a note tool says
news airline flybe has collapsed due to
chronic no way is that true wait what
was that search flybe collapsed to do
the chronovirus dude i heard that there
was one airline that asked everyone to
take like a month it happened yeah whoa
okay so eight hours ago it was on the
brink of collapse and 48 minutes ago it
is set to collapse within hours the
airline's done it's shutting down i
think so
dude some journalists posted a photo i
retweeted this and she saw that here's
my flight from london was it to london
to hong kong italy to milan
yeah it was empty no plane empty holy
moly yeah dude yeah she her parents were
going to go on vacation to italy and
they were like eh we're not going to go
anymore no you have to you have to
quantify at least a little bit who her
is because the average person's going to
be like someone that lives in the house
there's an individual here who yeah
who's uh yep yep yeah it doesn't matter
i know some parents that decided not to
go on their vacation yeah yeah because
it's happening who wants to go to italy
right now right i wouldn't i i kind of
do might be you would yeah there's a
journalist in you though that's why i
used to i dude i've gone to places where
like
i i when i was i was in turkey where i
was in turkey and i went to a
neighborhood with a bunch of big cameras
we were live and i literally had a bunch
of guys in black masks hold a molotov
cocktail up to like my face was it lit
so i'm like i'm calm i'm collected the
dude i was with was like we're cool man
we're cool we're cool like chill chill
chill and then i was just like i didn't
say much and i was just like nodding i
put my hands up we walked out and i said
to the dude i was like listen man you
know how you were saying we're cool
we're cool over and over again chill
chill it's all right it's all right yeah
do you know what he heard
doesn't speak english dude right you're
frantically waving your arms going
yeah no so i was like i put my hands up
like really slowly like yeah i turned
around and started walking they just
pointed i started walking i'm like i
don't know what they're saying i'm just
gonna they tell me to go i go i don't
think they want us here yeah i would
like to like he got he got his point
across like i'm going to throw this at
you if you stay here in the face with
like i don't need this it's the same
language but we understand what a
molotov versus language
yeah man yeah
but i think i you know i think i got
that out of my system because i still
have like you know luke uh rokowski is
always hitting me up like we gotta go
here and i'm like listen man
there was a time and a place and now
the bigger issue is that too many people
send me like threats and stuff and i'm
like yeah true i'm over it i can't i
can't you know but flying to italy like
during an outbreak
there'd be nobody there that would be so
fun where do you wear full goggles and
hazmat suit haven't you ever wondered
what hazmat suit yeah
you've all played fallout
definitely don't you want to have the
virtual experiment oh that's that's
that's insensitive i shouldn't say it
like whoa
what are you trying to say there tim
don't you want to see like what things
are like when this when something like
this happens
i mean
we are seeing what it's like no but i
mean like to be on the ground and
actually like
like experience to understand what's
happening when like industry shuts down
you walk around italy it's probably just
a ghost town yeah no one's no one's out
everyone's in their homes well i mean i
want to see it
i want to see it after sandy it was
crazy because new york was like a ghost
town yeah it was nuts i used to love
that after the snow storms we'd go out
and there's no one out yeah absolutely
yeah
so that's that's like a pleasant right
you're like oh it's lovely not like
you're ominous like dude after quiet
don't get used to that i'd like that
when when hurricane ahmed is deathly
quiet yeah sounds great
when hurricane sandy happened and the
water the water on the east side of
manhattan flooded what was it like set
like 10 feet or something ridiculous
amount yeah it was nuts i had a friend
who took a picture from her apartment
and it was like people standing up and
like climbing street poles because it
was like it came in so quick i went
there right the day out like maybe the
day after but right when the water
receded
you can see how like windows whey hype
were smashed out cars were spun around
like were floating down the street and
then like dropped in random places yeah
it was crazy
crazy
and the coolest thing i mentioned this
before was when the skateboarders were
skating on a downed bus stop and i'm
like yeah skateboarding i'm gonna gonna
get in trouble but thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show every monday
through friday at 8 p.m sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8pm monday through friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this youtube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows monday through
friday at 8pm thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next show
you